en proposant l'inscription de la
baguette la france a comblé les artisans
boulangers à l'initiative de cette
démarche
aujourd'hui ce qu'est ce que je tiens
dans les mains c'est notre patrimoine
c'est notre savoir faire d'autres
cultures cette traçabilité qu'on aura
justement grâce au patrimoine de
l'unesco
c'est la représentation en fait dues par
la française
et c'est auprès des boulangers
tourangeaux qui a été réalisé la partie
universitaire du dossier la boulangerie
gouro accueilli l'étude anthropologique
des mets mon petit grain de monter mon
petit grain si à l'édifice et puis et
tant mieux si on en est là aujourd'hui
on est dans notre quotidien
même si ça sort un petit peu d'ordinaire
ça reste voilà on reste dans des fuseaux
fille de notre fonctionnement quotidien
on essaie de faire du bon pain des
bonnes pâtisseries voilà comme avant et
après l'étude et avant et après le
positionnement à l'unesco
objet de science le savoir-faire du
boulanger est au coeur du dossier
accompagné par l'institut européen
d'histoire et des cultures de
l'alimentation
c'est important justement j'ai presque
envie d aussi pour montrer que c'est au
delà de la caricature au delà du
français avec sa baguette sous le bras
c'est derrière ça et même c'est d'abord
en réalité la question des savoir faire
artisanaux et on se lasse est important
c'est ça le patrimoine sur vous et donc
c'est pas juste anecdotique
on sait à quel point on est sensibles
aujourd'hui la protection à la
sauvegarde de ce savoir faire
là c'est aussi dans cette idée que cette
inscription est important l'étape de
dépôt du dossier est franchie
l'inscription au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité de la baguette de pain
française dépend maintenant de la
décision de l'unesco